así que está muy buenos días raúl pues a
eso se ha de sumar que también se ha
batido otro récord y el de las
hospitalizaciones en más de 88.000
personas están en los centros sanitarios
en eeuu o por problemas relacionados con
el coronavirus además también en un solo
día se registraron más de 174.000 casos
positivos la situación es realmente
preocupante por eso los centros para el
control y prevención de enfermedades
recomendaron a los estadounidenses en no
viajar para el día de acción de gracias
y al realizar las reuniones familiares a
través de internet sin embargo se
calcula que más de 50 millones de
personas se van a desplazar a lo largo
de estos días y son cinco millones de
menos de personas que el año pasado pero
el mensaje es claro que sobre todo la
gente es tenga muchísimas precauciones
si bien es cierto que el 75 por ciento
de ellos lo harán a través de carreteras
con sus vehículos privados el 25
está previsto que lo haga en avión aquí
ahora mismo la situación es más o menos
tranquila su primera hora aquí en el
aeropuerto internacional de miami pero a
lo largo de estos tres días antes de el
día de acción de gracias y que se han
visto un gran flujo de personas en los
aeropuertos
antonia pasar de todo esto que usted no
está hablando y estar en medio de una
pandemia caso está a eeuu la gente tiene
cierto miedo a volar
y hemos estado preguntando a los
pasajeros si tenían miedo decían que no
que llevando cubrebocas llevando también
gel sanitizante pues más o menos se
sentían tranquilos también el mensaje de
las aerolíneas es tranquilizador hay que
recordar que la asociación de transporte
aéreo internacional iata presentó un
pasaporte inmunitario para que la gente
se pudiera descargar una aplicación y
pudiera ver qué requisitos se necesitan
en cada uno de los países para entrar
dicen que hay que reactivar cuanto antes
la economía y aunque este fin de semana
podría ser un auténtico balón de oxígeno
para el sector turístico para recuperar
algo de lo que han perdido durante todo
este año raúl antonio buen día gracias
por toda la información por supuesto muy
pendientes de lo que ocurra en eeuu con
la pandemia y con el día de acción de
gracias